Nancy Pelosi has led Democrats in the
House of Representatives for more than
15 years and more and more of those
Democrats are fed up as of today more
than 50 Democrat congressman and
congressional candidates say they would
not support mrs. Pelosi for speaker if
the party retakes the majority you will
have a vote as part of the Democratic
caucus as to who will be the next
Democratic leader whether it be the
menorah lady or the Speaker of the House
will you vote for Nancy Pelosi probably
not you have said you will not support
Nancy Pelosi should you become elected
there as the next speaker or Democratic
leader in the house folks are ready for
a new generation of leadership would you
back Pelosi for Speaker if you win and
are in the house well I think again we
don't want to get ahead of ourselves hmm
mark Penn was a pollster and adviser to
both Bill and Hillary Clinton and he
joins us mark 15 years in the modern age
is a hell of a long time to be holding
down a party leadership job like this is
Nancy finally in trouble
I think trouble is kind of overrated
here look if the Democrats win the house
she will have done the fundraising the
messaging she will be in a very strong
position and she will be strengthened
herself most likely in California and
the California delegation is solidly
behind her so I don't actually think
she's going anywhere if she wins
on the other hand I think there are a
fair number of politicians that for the
purpose of the election because she's
unpopular nationally want to distance
themselves from her and I think
eventually there will be a change and
the other thing that could happen here
is the problem-solvers caucus if this
race is within five or six seats on
either way Democrats Republicans they
may hold up the election for Speaker
unless there are rules changes that put
some power back in the members hands
well let's let's just step back and talk
about what you said at the beginning
about whether she is in in trouble or
not
once upon a time if you were a loser you
got a second chance
whether it's Grover Cleveland Richard
Nixon whoever it is we're talking about
we live in much more brutal political
times and Nancy Pelosi hasn't actually
won in the house for ten years now four
five four elections and possibly a fifth
how is it what's the secret of her power
there how is it she's managed to hold
her grip on this caucus California
fundraising personality and organization
and remember what's happened here is
that the fundraising and the political
campaigns largely got centralized giving
more power to the leaders that's one of
the big reasons nothing gets done on
both sides because the leaders have too
much power and the members aren't free
to go agree on stuff well let's turn
from the Minority Leader to a well-known
New York City madam not any connection
between the two of them but the
self-described Manhattan Madame Kristin
Davis testified today before the Mulla
investigations grand jury why she did
that is unclear but miss Davis has been
a friend to longtime Trump advisor Roger
stone if you have difficulty keeping
your Metropolitan Madam's straight this
is the one who claim to have provided
hookers for Eliot Spitzer who was then
the Democrat governor of New York mark
what's what how did the mollow
investigation end up calling the
Manhattan Madame before the grand jury
well look I lived through 98th so I know
that there are no rocks which special
counsels will stop from turning over and
I think it's unfortunate that the
Special Counsel has gone down this road
I think Roger stone has been clear he
didn't collude with anybody he was up to
maybe some of his usual political tricks
and and bragging and they're obviously
interviewing everybody around him
regardless of the connection just as
they're interviewing everybody around
Trump quite interestingly one of Roger
Stone's other associates I think of mr.
Miller
sealed the subpoena and I think although
it was turned down at the district level
it's actually the most fascinating case
which might be the case that unravels
the entire Independent Counsel
investigation if it's appealed yeah
because the way this thing and that that
is a very interesting appeal because
this thing doesn't meet any basic
judicial norms what the special counsel
does basically he goes down the chain so
he wants to talk to this this madam
because she's got something on some
other guy and then he can put the
squeeze on that other guy and the other
guy can roll up another guy and
eventually somewhere in that chain
they'll find someone who is the goods on
Trump well why do Democrats and
Republicans put up with this why isn't
there a bipartisan understanding of the
need to get rid of this thing look I I
wish there were i I fought Ken Starr in
98 and I've been outspoken that I think
this investigation is wrong look I think
judge Ellis and the mana for trial
clearly knows that mana four is on trial
by the independent counsel with the
entire weight of the largest
prosecutorial machinery almost ever
built only because he spent two months
as Trump campaign manager yeah he might
have had an assessment he might have had
a trial but not two indictments not the
anat even even without bail even Harvey
Weinstein is out on a million dollars
bail right right so you you see that
this is not the way anybody really
expect the American justice system to
work and it I am puzzled that more
Democrats and Republicans are hatred for
Trump is so broad well I think people
are forgetting the first principles is
that we all have to agree on a system
that's fair to all and absolutely